[Music]
how many superheroes are in this movie
no one seems to know because we haven't
seen six-and-a-half seventy six and a
half who's there it's me
just the SonicWALL but I was with a
sawmill I don't know I don't I genuinely
don't think it's something like 32
actual hero and I heard the reverse of
outfit 23 a lot I don't know he's 23 22
or 32 take me was it ever crazy on set
with that many trailers and who had the
best trailer by the way we're done at
Union yeah always yeah he's got a
village real nature yeah it's the dog
Holly doesn't actually have a coat that
luncheon coat yeah it's very special to
be inviting including you feel quite
special what is it like being a part of
a movie that is expected to be the
biggest movie in the history of the
world like it's not often you do stuff
and they say well this could probably
movie the biggest thing in the history
of the world
Wow well I've been yeah [ __ ] I haven't
really yeah if you start worrying about
those kind of expectations you'll do I
think because you wouldn't bed for fear
in the morning and I think what they do
brilliant is they bring this massive
Liam off of a juggernaut of
multi-billion dollar franchise 18 plus
films in ten years together to this one
point we have a few cameras sometimes a
few summers just one and two directors
in this case a few cast and you just
plus the scene you get it better and
better and better and you're allowed to
play you're allowed to fail it's a safe
environment to try stuff out and fall
flat and then get up and do better so it
feels and the day like you're just
problem-solving on an average set
however there are moments when you sort
of step back and go this is huge it's
just monstrously big to a parent you
have to spend a lot of time together
yeah um have you figured out about
RuPaul yet because it has gone it is
gone viral I haven't heard of things I
wanna do social media I know you do a
bit but I saw these things filter
through this is the first I've heard
there's something that
dunno that he said went far well yeah
and he called it they asked who would be
best on RuPaul's Drag Race and you said
I said Downey would because he has the
fastest cars thinking a drag race car
race I didn't know about that lighten to
myself with it you've known like yes I
have were you entertained by it I
promise
masterfully and stained it's a great
show it's really fun yeah but yeah cuz
everyone I said it and everyone behind
the cameras was like kind of freaking
out oh my god he doesn't even know he
really was born yesterday
yeah you saw the Avengers billboard you
pulled over and you took a picture in
front of it and yeah a nice little quote
why why did you stop there for that
moment where was it
it was just somewhere here in LA I'm
just driving and I saw it and it blew my
mind because I was I remember when the
Avengers Assemble came out and I was
like first in line with one of my best
friends to go and see it and then we
then saw it five or six times after that
and just to be even involved or
associated with this this fantastic
universe that Kevin has created is such
a privilege but to play spider-man in a
film that I would have gone to see
anyway is just there's no words that
could describe how I feel right now so
when I saw it I got actually really
emotional because it's like a dream come
true it's I get literally as the
definition of a dream come true and I'm
so lucky because so few people get to do
that and and I just it was a really sore
we had a some of them are d23 as well we
all sat on stage watching the trailer
and this kind of clip cut together and
we'd all been coming on lined up and you
know fans were fantastic and on their
feet and weeping and then afters we sort
of had a humanities we're gonna be just
really tired and overworked or is this
something really special it just is it's
extremely
it's a moment in cinematic history
without being too pompous about it
because this is taken ten years it's
long form in cinema on the most huge
temple spectacle blockbuster kind of
stage and yet there are real lines of
integrity with character arcs as well as
the people who've been making this for
10 yrs have had lives and children and
families and it's it's huge on that
scale you know I'm not a numbers person
but just like thinking about that is
awesome
so be the tiny bar business yeah the
person I look at most on set is Kevin
Feige because this is his baby
you know who like to see his face when
he sees all of us walk on set it lights
up like he's looking at his first child
like it honestly is an amazing thing to
see and I often ask him like how is this
view and like this must be crazy and
he's like me so I kind of speechless man
on features is its original fan for you
man habits you just mentioned your
marble muscles explain that well you
know this is the idea man sun's out guns
out no I often compare marble to a gym
you know it's like hey morning Anthony
hey oh you do a minute boy Danny just
try some Twiggy condors what come down
that's a new form of Lokhande Michael
will come down no it's it's just there's
a lot of working out that goes into this
and also not just for sort of you know
coaches has shirts off moments but also
because the amount of stunt work could
create our fight scenes and why work you
have to be strong to do it so that yeah
it's a it's a it's a lot of Jimmy it's
an easy film to train for because we
have to share the screen with so many
yeah ripped people this is lots of
motivation are you looking around at
other people back oh my god he's I got a
good workout yeah you know
it goes around the Sun oh yeah your
platter massive it's really weird
but he'll blow your mind who blew your
mind when you went over their bodies yes
Chris Hemsworth why me I mean slightly
extraordinary is crazy a huge because
also the guy is like naked all the time
yes I think that's a bit of but yes so
he has no room there's no excuses with
this sure because he's just shirtless
all the time yeah it's not like he's got
his little tango and it's impressive
that's me you know I pump up and do all
the things you're supposed to do before
I do any of that and he's just like
what's up he's just there as it like the
perfect man you know it bothers me too
yeah we all do it